[Music]
class management often referred to as
classroom management is a set of
strategies and techniques used by
Educators to create an effective and
productive learning environment within a
classroom it involves establishing and
maintaining order discipline and a
positive atmosphere in the classroom to
maximize students learning opportunities
effective class management encompasses
setting clear expectations
maintaining students engagement
addressing behavioral issues and
creating a safe and inclusive space for
learning it aims to create an
environment where both students and
teachers can focus on academic growth
and
[Music]
development classroom management is
primarily aimed at preventing
disruptions in creating an environment
that promotes effective learning by
establishing clear rules routines and a
positive classroom atmosphere teachers
can minimize disruptions and create a
space where students can focus on their
studies engage in meaningful learning
experiences and reach their full
academic potential preventing and
intervening in classroom management
involves strategies to proactively
address and minimize disruptive behavior
and when necessary respond to such
behavior in a constructive manner here
are some key principles for both
prevention and
intervention the three most important
things things to prevent class
disruptions are clear expectations
establish and communicate clear and
specific expectations for behavior and
academic performance in the classroom
when students understand what is
expected of them they are more likely to
follow the rules and engage in the
learning process without causing
disruptions positive relationships build
positive teacher student Relationships
by creating a safe and respectful
classroom environment when students feel
valued respected and connected to their
teacher they're less likely engage in
disruptive
behavior prevention establish clear
expectations communicate clear and
specific expectations for behavior and
academic performance to students ensure
they understand what is expected of them
create a positive classroom environment
Foster a positive and welcoming
atmosphere where students feel safe
respected and valued proactive classroom
design organize the physical layout of
the classroom to minimize distractions
Andre create a conducive learning
environment routines and procedures
develop consistent routines and
procedures for various classroom
activities Transitions and materials
management engaging lessons plan and
deliver engaging lessons that capture
students interest and maintain their
attention intervention immediate
response address disruptive behavior
promptly to prevent it from escalating a
calm and immediate response can be more
effective than delayed consequences
logical consequences apply logical and
age appropriate consequences for
misbehavior ensuring that they are
related to the behavior and have a
purpose in teaching
responsibility conflict resolution teach
conflict resolution skills both to
prevent conflicts and to help students
resolve them constructively restorative
practices in cases of harm or conflict
consider using restorative practices to
encourage understanding empathy and
Reconciliation desk organization in the
classroom is crucial for creating an
efficient and productive learning
environment effective desk organization
helps students Focus find materials
quickly and promotes a productive
classroom
[Music]
environment
okay
[Music]
than